Il y a eu un moment un petit peu compliqué à tourner dans cette vidéo.
Voilà, je vous l'donne en mille
C'est Julfou qui doit cracher !
*rires de Cyprien et Julfou*
C'est dégueulasse a tourner ça, non ?
Oui ! *rires* Y'a tout les éléments pour que ce soit dégeulasse.
*rires*
Oh putain !
Mec, ton crachat il a fait un slide sur la huître.
Il a fait "je reviens vers Julfou"
On en parle ou pas que c'est dégueulasse ?
*rires*
comme si il y avait pas assez de trucs dégueulasses
il s'est dit tant qu'à faire ma morve me revienne dessus
c'est ton crachat ça ?
c'est un mélange des deux mec attend
ça te plait ou pas ? *rire*
oh putain
*Se gratte le fond de la gorge pour cracher*
ça te plait ou...
? *rire*
Bêtisier est dégueulasse
Han c'est dégueulasse *rire*
Ah mec ça m'donne envie d'vomir attends
Ha ouais? *rire*
Ca ne lâche pas, en faite, le concept c'est que c'est infini
Tu jettes ça Squeezie ? Prends par le bas, vraiment par le bas. -Non mais vraiment par le bas *rire*
-Je le mets ou ? -Dans une poubelle -Ahhhh!
Bon, on va pouvoir jeter tout ça...
Ah ça te plait?
Voire changer de métier..
Merci Julfou!
Tchô!